And you actually are a very classically trained pianist, jazz musician,...
...and one of our video questions from leopardscar20 actually is about your,...
leopardscar?
...leopardscar, leopardscar20,...
...asking a little bit about your training ongoing, so we'll go ahead and roll that video.
Hey, Gaga! This is Rudy Hernandez, one of your little monsters from Portland, Oregon.
My question is, I was just wondering if you still took...
...piano training and vocal training to improve your skills?
Be great to hear you answer my question.
I can't wait to see you again here in Portland, Oregon and paws up!
Cutie! I love my fans!
Yes. I actually vocally rehearse every single day.
I do a 30 - minute warm-up every single day.
It's been the same vocal warm-up that I've been doing since I was 11 years old.
I've had my mentor, Don Lawrence, has been my voice teacher since I was 11,...
...so it's over 10 years now.
And in terms of piano,...
...piano is funny; I mean it's kind of this thing that always stays with you.
I don't know if there's any pianist in this room,...
...but if you don't practice for a little while,...
...and then you focus on it, you kinda get your chops back pretty quickly.
So, what I do mostly for piano is I try to find time when I'm in New York City...
...or on the road to do shows and have jam sessions with my band just for fun. So,...
...whenever you see those really horrid photos of me looking drunk at a piano bar,...
...I'm actually rehearsing.
That's just how I like to rehearse.
I like to have a couple martinis and play some Cole Porter,...
...and that's just the way I like to learn.
But stay in school!